[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya des tirs dans le 10e
arrondissement des rues les rues donne
dans les rues et louise est en ligne
avec la paix mais c'est reste au bureau
il regroupe tout le monde ya une équipe
au stade de france et l'otan parisse a
attiré rue bichat au carillon rue de la
fontaine au rang séverine tu pars au
stade de france avec ton équipe les
théories sont entre au bataclan en plein
concert
[Applaudissements]
on est évidemment préparé pour ça mais
ceux pour qui la charge émotionnelle est
trop importantes peuvent se mettre sur
le côté
je peux pas qu'on laisse place à nos
émotions personnelles aux dernières
informations il y aurait deux
terroristes en fuite dans paris
je veux que le moindre type qui a eu un
comportement bizarre dans les dernières
24 heures soit en garde à vue
faisait qu elle sort du 13e rang
tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est clamé qui vous frappe
encore nous frapper
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone pour une
autre livraison d'or
tout est lié c'est quoi son nom
c'est le connaît on n'a rien sur lui
comment vous l'avez récupérer l'adresse
je les suis vous avez travaillé en
dehors de toute procédure
numéro toile a rassemblé toi moi j'ai
besoin de voir
comment est ce possible que vous n'ayez
rien ça fait trois jours maintenant
je sais sont des deux terroristes